j'aimerais vous poser quelques questions
très simples tout d'abord j'aimerais
vous parler de l'écriture pour vous
écrire est ce que c'est une chose
sporadiques ou bien à ses cadences et
pour vous bien pour moi c'est une
horreur d'écrire j'adore formuler des
phrases tout ça mais c'est vrai que
exercent des fautes à tous les maux
clairement je l'avais je l'aï signalé qu
un demi degré de jessica alors on t'a
connu dans les marseillais saissac
excusé dans les mains ces sujets pas du
tout suivi les marci je regarde jamais
le brésil ben j'ai été un peu partout et
puis et puis avec mes collègues et voilà
que tu faisais quoi la base on fait à la
base c'est moi c'est plutôt de musique
merci oui j'étais coiffeuse avant ça
adacore ouais bah si je suis étudiant
venu nous voir et apprêtée peut-être les
rentrées de remercier comment parce que
j'ai été casté est tout simplement mais
j'étais en couple avec julien à l'époque
il faisait déjà la télé donc c'est ça
était peu avec lui maintenant
ah non non non non non non le pr non non
non non non non non non et donc tu étais
dans les mares si les marseillais en
fait c'est des gens qui viennent de
marseille et qui vont en voyage grâce à
la production pour faire des voyages et
pour ce show en fait c'est ça il ya un
peu de paix chaud mais pas que pour ça
mais en fait c'est quoi le but des
marseillais jamais compris cette
émission les marchés tout simplement un
groupe qui part à l'étranger et on a des
jobs est tout simplement que la boucle
luton et il faut réussir ces jobs est
sur les rails
ben on retourne en france quoi d'accord
c'était de la faune alors ton livre
c'est tout moi alors c'est qu'il écrit
vraiment oui je les crée avec une
personne évidemment parce que moi il
faut que la ponctuation c'est pas fait
pour moi d'accord ouais donc voilà dix
jours à compter de vraiment ça me tenait
à coeur de raconter ma vie est de savoir
que les gens sachent d'où je viens quoi
n'est pas inquiété alors t'es qu'une
petite fille turbulente est ce que tu
dis parce que moi je lis que ce qu'il ya
derrière
non mais et habiter dans une caravane
oui tu y arriver j'habite dans une
caravane jusqu'à mes 6 ans ah ouais et
après on supposer mais oui j'ai grandi
en caravane super né avec une cuillère
en or dans la bouche comme les gens
peuvent penser donc est aujourd'hui t'as
combien de tap - de follower sur un
store trois millions sept premiers sets
et aujourd'hui tu vis de ça le thé poste
de t2 je vis de mes business que j'ai
montée j'ai des sociétés gm parfum j'ai
plein de chasse des parents sont fiers
de toi aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils sont
très fiers de moi ça aurait vraiment way
we will virale dites moi j'ai vu le
livre alors effectivement c'est pas la
grande littérature mais c'est pas ce
qu'on recherche quand
libre moi je note que c'est très sincère
c'est très juste et très honnête très
honnête vraiment en entend votre voix
alors il ya des maladresses mais moi
j'ai bien aimé il ya des zones dont vous
venez vite et pas les sujets vous parlez
beaucoup d'alliés aussi des femmes
battues et je trouve qu'il y avait
vraiment des idées très joli moment et
je pense que pour les fans de jessica ça
arrive idéal en fait ouais c'est vrai
nom est alors jessica vous m'avez dit
doug maybee vous mais sirigu fait
l'apologie de la chirurgie esthétique
vous vous avez dit en arrivant mais dit
t'as vu j'ai refait tous ces portables
tout retaper assume totalement
ah ouais c'est ballon glissant ça se
voit donc carrément donné j'ai pas dire
c'est pas vrai non mais c'est très bien
fait franchement il est mieux aller
après du coup non franchement non c'est
très bien fait atteindre fait quoi en
fait a le nez le menton
alors le menton et mieux que celui des
bogdanov et donc ouais t'as fait le nez
le menton
j'ai fait des objections mais ta culotte
mais je vais avoir 30 ans où la règle
besoin de faire ça comme moi hein mais
toi tu as besoin comme on sait si tard
parce que pour tous les jeunes qui nous
regardaient ce que est ce que tu penses
que c'est pas un mauvais exemple de
donner voilà cet exemple de faire
beaucoup de chirurgie esthétique il ya
plein de jeunes filles pour qui tu es un
exemple
toi tu dis voilà tu dis voilà moi je le
fais parce que je me sens mieux dans ma
peau mais elles ne sont pas obligées de
le faire et de faire comme toi quoi non
bien sûr je l'espère leur monnaie est
bien décidé à des opérations le montant
gelé très très mal vécu j'ai failli
partir en dépression et joyeux mais tout
enlever ouais je l' ai très mal vécu au
début mais je conseille pas du tout
faire la chirurgie esthétique au jeune
fille moi je le fais j'ai 30 ans ça y
est maintenant mais j'ai trouvé dans le
routier sika avant une photo jessica
avant et aujourd'hui donc tu as fait le
menton et sinon tu as fais d'autres
choses là j'ai refait dès qu'on fait la
bouche parce qu'on avait massacré
alouettes avait la bouche triomphé en
fait assez à la voile avait une bonne
chère moment c'est un média mais voilà
alors donc ça me fait tout avant ouais
et ben alors les têtes chaudes tu sais
pas y'a pas un gros changement en
jeûnant et c'est tout léger à chaque
fois vrai mais ça alors la chirurgie
esthétique
si vous voulez savoir si c'est bien fait
il faut pas que ça se remarque
affonteront mario pas non mais c'est
vrai voilà maintenant que ça se voit
quand même aux transports maintenant on
fait quoi
oui mais encore bien comment ça sert à
rien en faire mais bon voilà et
indélicat c'est délicat
non mais c'est bête c'est parce que je
me vois tout le temps la télé j'ai
toujours mon retour j'ai les
commentaires sont des gens puisque
malgré tout bas les gens et ils te clash
sur ton physique et puise yvan fort
ouais et du coup ben finalement de ne
pas remarquer les défauts et puis ça te
perturbé limite je pense qu'à ça et
quand je me voyais profils dont moi je
me vois pas évidemment dans le miroir
moment dont je me dérangeait pas mais
vrai profil quand j'avais mon retour
d'image
oui je me sais j'en ai parlé ou alors tu
avais pas de manteau tout à fait
rajouter un menton voilà j'ai mis un
coup classique belge benjamin castaldi
fait pareil avec une fonction l'assument
c'est bien sûr la charge de nettoyer pas
de problème avec ça
non mais c'est vrai j'ai fait des
positions je ne disais pas de vous avez
fait qu'aucune hypothèse une liposuccion
j'ai fait j'ai refait un peu les dents
aussi mais oui mais voilà les effets les
dons le menton le nez les pommettes non
pas les pour m
alors moi ça non d'accord la poitrine ah
oui d'accord et le fessier le fessier
puisqu'il par excellence à la mode
maintenant pas encore le film c'est en
projet non mais
georges à l'enfant que j'éclate que je
ressemble plus à rien oui je retape
records jeux ludiques l'air d'accord
vous en êtes aujourd'hui un sentimental
ans que c'est la servane d'un soir je
suis marié je suis très heureux d'accord
vous allez avoir un enfant bientôt
j'espère parce que je peux le circoncire
on t'adore qu'est ce qui va se passer
dans les marseillais la prochaine saison
la pn chose que les problèmes des
problèmes souvent c'est une saison avec
vous êtes une bourde un problème là il
va se passer quoi gens n'ont pas une
chose et coupe des séparations une des
histoires ça se passe où là il vous a
mené ou maintenant on attend les parties
direction l'asie mais on est parti en
chine au vietnam en asie on aimerait
bien sûr c'est un petit peu partout asie
chine vietnam tout ça c'était génial je
parle mieux n'ont rien à voir d'accord
vous êtes parti partout en fait fait que
voyager ou le voyage est payé pour faire
c'est que ces conneries vous êtes payés
on peut savoir à peu près comme au vert
payez vous faire cesser non je vais pas
le dire se débarrasser vélo me faut un
choc je peux le savoir 1 c'est un coup
de fil je le sais tout de suite alors
oui c'est une des plus connues donc elle
peut négocier quoi la gagne ou perde à
combes et sont payés à peu près alors
les cachets production c'est entre oui
ça doit être ça entre dix et vingt mille
suivant le candidat pour toute la saison
mais pourrait pas saison d'accord on va
très bien dit voilà non non non non
c'est moi quoi c - oui nature wii ps2
mis tout va non non c'est moi que c'est
moins que dix ou vingt mille pour toute
la saison
ça n'est pas les candidats oui mais vous
par exemple moi c'est
c'est plus que ce qu'on va me demande si
je vais le savoir si je vous dis vas
arrêter de montréal était derrière c'est
le même groupe que moi c'est la même
production chez un coup de fil à passer
j'ai ton contrat demain donc les
colonies non car effet bien vaut mieux
que tu dis la vérité maintenant sinon je
vais là savoir demain ça m'a foutu un
bordel pas possible pas loin ce n'est
pas loin de dire non c'est pas bon pour
le dire un confidentiel
ah oui bon on va pas simple du coup tu
pendant la pub vous seront sera tout ça
vous inquiétez pas magali bertaud pouvez
le dire vous mais moi je suis sûr entre
10 et 20 d'accord basculement les
candidats et candidates et en plus
anciens de votre nouveau et c'est un
gars qui gagne 200 euros par jour c'est
bon d'être qui sont à cinq et six
semaines de tournage
d'accord il te calculé en jour 1c 200 à
500 euros par jour
pas pour aller franchement pour aller
voyager c'est certain c'est un tour du
monde ça ouais bah c'est sympa on fait
le tour de monde en plus de 2 500 euros
ya du travail derrière la cdu freud on
les voit rien du travail quoi il a quoi
mettre des morts au fil des maillots
les mauriciens
[Musique]
je travaille vraiment fort attention
wikia qu'est ce que c'est vrai que ça
vous fait même perdre de l'argent par
rapport à vos partenariats clés vous
empêche de les faire voilà je travaille
bien mais je vous jure il ya des heures
j'en fais pas la grasse mat on doit être
toujours présent
c'est comme du cinéma sauf à
l'impostaire voilà qui a pas d'histoire
hier au sénat on s'amuse bien quand même
et à droite adore les gens qui sont deux
n'ont jamais regardé les charrier jamais
regarder ses émissions mais je trouve
moi c'est franchement je l'aurais fait
je l'aurais fait jour a pu le faire
ouais s'il avait fait le tunisien à
miami
[Rires]
[Musique]